[Música]
duzentos anos dois séculos novo gerações
é muito tempo não é 2º fórum econômico
mundial é o tempo que temos que esperar
para alcançar a igualdade de gênero se
continuamos a ser a minha pergunta é
podemos esperar esse tempo o planeta vai
agüentar todo esse tempo
não vou falar aqui de mobilidade humana
em termos de mobilidade física vou falar
de mobilidade social
o falar de desigualdade e vou falar de
mobilidade social vou falar de
transformação
vou falar de liberdade por falar de
igualdade de gênero
primeiro de tudo gostaria de agradecer a
no início do ano pelo convite
a unisuam - lugar especial para mim
porque foi uma das primeiras reuniões
que fiz quando cheguei ao rio de janeiro
para ser cônsul geral do que nada aqui
no rio de janeiro
portanto é a minha primeira vez em bangu
sempre ouvi falar de bangu como o lugar
mais quente do estado do rio de janeiro
e agora que estou em frente de vocês
fazendo a minha primeira falar de tx
estou sentindo esse calor então não sei
se vocês conheceram o meu chefe que o
primeiro ministro do canadá
ele é feminista quando chegou ao poder
em 2015
ele nomeou um gabinete da metade de
mulheres se ea metade de mim homens
também no meio muitas a mulheres em
posições de influência no canadá e
recomendo é nomeação da governadora
geral do canadá que é engenheira açúcar
na alta e fala não sei quantos idiomas
também nas amamos uma política externa
feminista porque sabemos que as
sociedades mais igualitárias são mais
cós pêra e mais segura
então como chefe de uma missão
diplomática cana dele se é o mesmo
trabalho de promover os valores
canadense de protecção e promoção dos
direitos humanos respeito da diversidade
da inclusão ea igualdade de gênero então
faz coisa e três anos que estou aqui
como vendo esses valores e apoiando
iniciativas para aumentar a participação
das mulheres em todos os setores da
sociedade
o certo é político e econômico nas
forças armadas há no setor audiovisual
nas carteiras tanques são as carreiras
de ciência tecnologia engenharia
matemática mas virou uma paixão
acredito com fundamente dos benefícios
da igualdade de gênero além de centros e
formatação também engenheira
meus pais sempre me apoiaram nos meus
estudos e me disseram você pode fazer o
que quer na sua vida
infelizmente tem 130 milhões de meninas
que estão fora da escola e se forem tem
50% menos chance de terminar a escola
segunda área que se os colegas do sexo
masculino
talvez elas tenham um sono cds e
engenheiras médicas psicólogas
empreendedoras mas nunca vão poder
alcançar os seus sonhos é uma perda para
ela
mas se o papel da parte a sociedade
interna
não sei se vocês conhecemos o estudo da
mckinsey que seja mal poder da
habilidade
segundo esse estudo se as mulheres
pudessem terra um papel idêntico ao dos
homens no mercado de trabalho poderíamos
adicionar 28 milhões de dólares no clima
global
poderíamos aumentar o pib global por 26%
isso equivalentes às economias
dos estados unidos e da china
juntas que são as duas maiores economias
do mundo
então a questão da igualdade de gênero
não é só uma questão moral e social
é uma questão econômica crítica e as
mulheres no poder semarh cansasse o
potencial econômico
maximo a economia global sofrerá também
as empresas que conheçam o poder da
verde da cidade que estão trabalhando
sobre esse tema porque tem vários
estudos que comprovam a relação entre a
presença de mulher a na liderança de
empresas e retornos financeiros quanto
mais diversidade e mais mulheres é na
liderança da empresa
mas essas empresas têm chances de ter né
a deter é retornos financeiros a acima
da média da sua indústria nacional
empresas mais diversas são empresas mais
inovadoras e mais reativa e isso faz
sentido quando você pensar bem se você
tem um grupo homogêneo tomando uma
decisão um grupo de mesmo gênero meu é
da mesma preferência sexual mesma
religião que estudaram mesmo tipo de
escolas que vêm dos mesmos bairros
quando eles vão chegar a uma decisão não
percebe a tal boa qualidade que se fosse
um grupo diversificado como olhares
diferentes
então vimos os benefícios de ter
mulheres para a economia para as
empresas mas tem vários benefícios
também para na política então a semana
passada tivemos eleições no canadá e
elegemos e 29 por cento de mulheres no
parlamento
estamos longe da qualidade dos 50
porcentos mas estamos no caminho certo
porque em 2015 se eu tínhamos 26% eo
garrão em que
as mulheres estão envolvidas na política
está correlacionado com sociedades menos
cultas com uma renda nacional mais alta
e com também menos probabilidade de
conflito armado
e como nas empresas que têm uma
liderança diversificada a mesma coisa no
parlamento onde as mulheres vão talvez
prestar atenção a coisas diferentes e é
esse vamos é que as mulheres por exemplo
vai prestar mais atenção a questões
sociais como a educação e saúde não
começando a minha fala eu contei para
vocês
se o planeta pode aguentar do santos mas
nos de desigualdade porque estava me
referindo às mudanças climática
climáticas que o problema mais complexo
que estamos enfrentando
nesse momento as mudanças climáticas têm
um impacto diferente homens e mulheres
muitas vezes são as mulheres que são
responsáveis pela produção de alimentos
para coletar a água para o fornecimento
de combustíveis para o aquecimento e
para recuse a mas com as mudanças
climáticas todas as tvs se tarefa se
estão votando mais se mais deficiência
eventos climáticos extremos como
inundações e secas têm um impacto maior
sobre os mais pobres e os mais
vulneráveis
infelizmente 70% dos mais pobres no
mundo o som do sexo feminino as mulheres
têm um papel único para a mitigação ea
adaptação para as mudanças climáticas
elas têm um bom conhecimento uma
compreensão de que precisamos fazer é a
nossa dá tapas mudanças climáticas e
buscar soluções práticas
infelizmente as mulheres são ainda um
recurso à premente inex provado
direitos inscritos até terra falta de
acesso a recursos financeiros a
treinamento
a tecnologia e falta de acesso á a acs
esferas e tomada de decisão fazem com
que elas muitas vezes não podiam ter um
papel pleno no enfrentamento das
mudanças climáticas
então seguimos como essas mulheres
também a presença de mulheres pode
ajudar para a economia ea política
também dando às mudanças climáticas
agora quero falar de um impacto quando
tem muita desigualdade numa sociedade
quero falar de violência contra as
mulheres em cima que 35% das mulheres no
mundo tenham sofrido um a violência
física ou sexual
isso quer dizer que uma de cada três
mulheres será estruturada espancada ou
abusada ao longo da sua vida
estamos falando de uma de cada três
mulheres
então a começo a me emociono um
pouquinho sobre esse tema é é uma então
são mulheres que estão ao redor de vocês
são suas irmãs oeste as suas avós suas
colegas de universidade e suas colegas
de trabalho e à violência contra a
mulher não acontecer por causa por acaso
enquanto mais desigualdade tem uma
sociedade mais altos são os níveis de
violência contra a mulher e o contrário
também é verdadeiro sociedades mais
igualitárias são mais seguras para todos
os dados não deixam dúvidas um dos
melhores indicadores de estabilidade e
prosperidade de um país e conta com bem
atacamos as mulheres não quero que
desgarrou bazil amor base
me sinto muito bem aqui por isso que
quero compartilhar essa informação com
vocês a se fecham brasil da violência
contra a mulher são a romântica o um eco
é cada quatro minutos uma mulher é
agredida no brasil de forma física
psicológica ou sexual
cada 2 duas horas uma mulher é morta no
brasil por causa da violência contra a
mulher e as escolas não estão melhorando
em 2018 os crimes de ódio contra a
mulher aumentaram por 12% assistir às
duas semanas a o lançamento do mapa do
ódio é ea ouvir falar de uma estatística
é que me espantou em 2018
mais de 300 mil mulheres pediram
protecção à justiça
são 300 mil mulheres que tinham medo por
sua vida
a violência contra a mulher é uma
pandemia global que afeta todos os
países em todas as classes sociais
por isso que se lançou uma campanha
internacional que se chama de 7 até
ativismo contra a violência contra a
mulher
começando o dia 25 de novembro que o dia
em internacional para a eliminação da
violência contra a mulher e termina no
dia 10 de dezembro que o dia
internacional dos direitos humanos em um
período que podemos usar para refletir e
para a a ver o que podemos fazer sobre
esse tema e se você olhar perto de você
podemos dar as camisas da violência
contra a mulher em penha que a da
sexistas querem baixar as mulheres na
linguagem que usamos antes mensagens
midiáticas que o objetivo fica mais
mulheres glorifique a masculinidade tec
tóxica e também nas normas rígidas de
gênero que quem como sempre crianças
pequenas
mas tem cinco ações que você pode tomar
a ser aliado a sls enfrentamento da
violência contra a mulher
primeiro ouça este já aberto para
aprender com essas diferenças dos outros
dois
acredite apoio sobreviventes e pessoas
afetadas pela violência
fale adiciona sua voz para denunciar a
violência inter venha encontrem uma
maneira segura de ajudar quando quando
você vê atos de violência baseada no
gênero e haja dois eo tempo as
organizações que lutam contra a
violência e seja a mudança que você
desejava
quero vou deixar vocês com um crescendo
menos 200 28 e 5 200 são duas 200 anos
de vida igualdade não queremos esperar
tanto tempo 28 trilhões
é o que estamos perdendo porque não
temos igualdade de gênero e cinco são as
maneiras em que você pode ajudar no
enfrentamento da violência contra a
mulher
todos nós temos um papel para aumentar a
igualdade de gênero e reduzir a
violência contra a mulher
convido todos vocês a fazer parte dessa
transformação para que tenhamos um mundo
melhor porque dá pela sua atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]